every little noise of them makes me feel
sick suppose you are knocked out enough
to bear this have any second left-handed
rally sir what is the chore of an old
friend is out here captain Stan you
don't want to join them they may have a
hell of a time of it it's just what I'm
hoping for
you haven't been in the army five
minutes of
our company commander you know hello
Stan
you'll find him changed
he said this company throw all sorts of
rocking times big strain on a man he
used to come and stay with me my sister
Margaret in the holidays she is
beautiful she way to move
I don't want to see how short I am
[Music]
we won't last five minutes if the
Germans attack you'll to stay where you
are for as long as you can
when's that expected today after
tomorrow
this waiting's I think someone to the
headmaster
they've sent us here to die
all these youngsters do not realize how
lucky they are
or does it matter they all feel like we
do
and glands yummy together
I can't stick around do you think this
terrific
- what about compare
there is a job to be done my darling
I mean to go through this is a mistic
addict
is the only thing that this man can't
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you